good morning John I wrote this song a
while ago when farmville was a little
bit more culturally relevant let's just
be honest we've all got a lot of wilted
crops out there but the good news is
that the cows and the chickens and the
pigs that they never die no matter how
much you neglect them they're alive I
[Music]
just made a discovery that made us
change my life while I was looking
through this newfangled books
I don't like it
one player I much rather
I dragged my ragged to work I can barely
never set it John
you must become a millionaire it's is so
much more fun than playing solitaire
and animals that boom
there's never said it's done
Oh
thank you to everyone who helped me with
this video all the people who submitted
photo Mitrano fication x' what is the
product that i'm working on we were
testing the beta if you were following
me on twitter you've got to find out
about that sorry to everyone where it
didn't work for you it's very much in
beta it doesn't work with with one of
the lesser-known browsers it's called
Firefox
yeah that's embarrassing but we're
working on it I've got some other plans
for this software and it's gonna be
pretty amazing also another thing that
we're doing differently with this song
is I'm actually releasing it as a single
on iTunes I've never done this before
and I don't know if I'm ever gonna do it
again but I figured I'd do it this one
time just to see how it goes and I had
people submit their farms so that I
could use them in the artwork for the
digital single and I only ended up using
one of those because somebody actually
submitted a farm in which they had
written nerdfighters in their farm with
farmville stuff so thank you to Abbey
for providing the basis of the artwork
for the digital single the link to
purchase of course is in the doobly-doo
I hope you liked it John I will see you
on Wednesday